how many people in their lifetimes do a
job that they love doing maybe I have
EDD but I want to be able to do
everything why can't we do everything
people have to like you or relate to you
for who you are you can't be someone
else at youth
hello believe nation I'm Evan Carmichael
my one word is believe and I believe
that entrepreneurs are going to solve
all of the major problems of the world
so to help you on your journey today
we're going to learn from one of India's
highest paid and most popular actresses
Priyanka Chopra and my take on our top
ten rules of success volume 2 rule
number 2 is my personal favorite and I'd
love to know which one you guys like the
back and as always guys if you're
watching if you hear something that
really resonates with you please leave
it down in the comments below put quotes
around it so other people can be
inspired and when you write it down it's
much more likely to stick for yourself
as well enjoy
let's see what is the choice that you
walk a path like everyone else
Justin foots go to work and come back
and never have a legacy or you swim
upstream like a trout against norm and
then whatever little you achieve is only
yours it's not like everyone else and
I'd rather have something that is my
path paved by me something that is my
legacy my own selves my own achievement
than being one of the many successful
people in the world I just love what I
do
and I'm good at it and I love the
ability to wake up in the morning and
say oh my god I get to go to work I mean
how many people in their lifetimes do a
job that they love doing most people do
it's a survival it's how we need to feed
our families we need to survive it's a
career okay we have to do it but to wake
up with you know my my feet and my my
fingers tingling and say wow I have this
to do with that to do today and it's an
amazing feeling and I don't take it for
granted I'm a storyteller and I am NOT
someone who restricts myself to one
thing ever I've never been that person
maybe I have EDD but I want to be able
to do everything why can't we do every
sexual you know as an especially women
we are must with great at multitasking
so I want to produce I want to have a
business I'm good I'm producing here I'm
going to produce in India Hindi films
regional film I want to be able to act
on them maybe not you know there's so
many things that I can do which I want
to be able to explore I'm a little how
to say this
I have people call it arrogance I call
it self assurance but I am Who I am you
like it grave you don't like it I don't
care that's who I've always been so
whether I'm coming to America whether I
go to India
I'm always true to just who I am if you
try and change yourselves according to
thinking that oh I'm going to a
different country or you know I need to
please or I need to
not being alien enough or you're
overthinking it
people have to like you or relate to you
for who you are you can't be someone
else
certainly so I've stayed very true to
who I am whether it it's in India or
here I mean as much as I can of course
you have to be open to understand and
accept the fact that you won't know
everything yes and people won't know
everything about you so it's an
education I'm enjoying so much educating
my cast my crew and the people that I
meet about India a char in biryani and
Diwali and as they see as it gets and
they have so much fun getting to know
India through me and me the same way so
it has to you have to accept your
uniqueness when my publicist I remember
email me because you want to be in the
list y'all can sit your can being
considered in the because they're voting
and stuff is going on in 100 most
influential people are like wow and we
consider that and if death was the
achievement for me there aren't
consideration with this lot of people
then to be a part of the list then to be
on the cover of the magazine not just in
Asia but in the US as well I mean I and
then to have my part missionary within
10 years he was right but Miss Lee
Priyanka Chopra yeah one week was like a
real big pinch me moment but but tell me
there's all this stuff right there is of
course the sweat I mean you talked about
your days about you know signing here
for weekends but what is the sacrifice
you make to achieve this talk about your
life really lightly work completely I
need get to meet my friends in Bombay
only for the 20 days that I might come
here now for this year at least my
family yes I can fly them down to be in
a completely new country get to know new
people you know reintroduce yourselves
and see if these are send for life or
not it's
not just the fact that that's all I do
but it's such a solitary thing to do I'm
willing to sacrifice my sleep I'm
willing to sacrifice food and willing to
sacrifice quality of life if that's what
you want to call it and to be able to
achieve to be an achiever because to be
an achiever you have to let go of some
things I make it a point that I fly my
family wherever I am I fly my friends
wherever I am I might fly my cook
wherever I am because I need my Hindi I
need my doll travel at night it's very
important well so merely cook them is
actually important confuse them is
exactly the decides that I think you
know when you want global domination you
pay the price for it I like pushing the
envelope I like pushing myself actually
that it's a very selfish thing I'm I'm
very weak I have a very short attention
span I get bored with you know it's hard
to do the same thing when something
doesn't challenge me I'm in a profession
where I can push myself so much and I
live with adrenaline of of you know
working best under pressure some up and
I'm very fortunate that I get ruled that
has written for me which which give me
the ability to do that so why not yeah
you have any advice that you can give
entrepreneurs or people who are trying
to break out of their comfort zone well
it is scary I will always say that you
know especially business because it's a
very scary place to be in it changes it
goes ups and it has so many ups and
downs but a very very dear friend of
mine in a mentor Jimmy Iovine
who created beats by dre works for now
Apple music
he told me this one one piece of advice
which I did not have I get he said to be
successful you have to be able to walk
away from a deal you have to if you want
it bad enough then people are going to
give it to you at buttons you know but
you have to be able to walk away from a
deal that's when you become stronger and
you have more confidence in yourself so
that's the that's how I've started
living my life and I guess that's the
advice I would give all young
entrepreneur answer just think about
to make that you think about I know it's
also too early to ask but do you think
about where you will be five years later
I mean I'm hopefully I will still be
working what as what where how I've
never known I'm not someone who planned
my career I'm very instinctive I if I
like something I'd do it hence the
reason I fail a lot also because you
know I take this chances I don't like I
mean I it's very easy to have a nice
career so but I want to be able to have
a path which is mine yeah screw up
sometimes but it's mine no one else did
it before me it's so it's it's
completely you know empty territory
until I get there my footprint I think a
lot of pride in that mean so I don't
know where it'll be but it will be
different I can assure you it'll be
something that would it'll be a
precedent I like setting will be
breaking new ground yeah I want to do
things that people are like oh sure
thing that I look for things like that
whether it's acting - do you think I
don't know what it will be Mia I don't
know I am I was I was very fascinated
with with show business and I joined
movies and I found so many sad stories
of people who after they become
superstars what they realize that
they're superstars you know the downfall
it's going to happen to everyone
everyone I knew that the first out of my
first film so I'm not afraid of it I
just know that I'll have for Plan B when
I when that happens creativity can be
most into so many things it can actually
I write I think I I write columns are
written for L in your times in the Santa
I act in movies on producing served
there's a gazillion things you can do as
a creative person so I'm prepared for
that so yeah but I do believe you can't
ever sit down on your hand and right now
I'm stop but you want to challenge me to
wing it in context I am this is insane
no one challenges me on my show I'm the
good luck charm you want to do this I
think we should you know all right all
right these already look hot yes so
these are in premise our from atomic
wings here in New York they're made with
their nuclear hot sauce and I have
sebastio just in case that's not enough
and I have milk just in case it's too
much so we think I might need the milk I
might yeah whoever eats the most Wings
within 20 seconds wins yeah let's get
video 20 seconds on the clock
yeah
ready any mark get set go
120 101 I couldn't even do one I got a
big a big a big chunky one my first
balloon was a big way oh I was gonna do
it
who doesn't love this person right here
yeah it does
[Applause]
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed if you want to get your
pick of who I should profile next in the
top tens check out the link in the
description and go and cast your vote I
also wanted to give a quick shelter to
Russel Duvall Russel thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book your
one word I really appreciate the support
man and I hope you're enjoying the read
so thank you guys again for watching
I believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
success is not its success in our
destination people always think that oh
my god this person feel successful
because they've had a successful movie
or successful show but success is a
journey you have to consistently always
always be successful that's when you're
really successful because otherwise
you'll be remembered for your last
failure and I had a few but I just have
to compensate for my failure by just
getting up and running the more time you
take to sort of mourn it you're wasting
that much more time in being successful
so you just have to you know work up
take a self up dust ourselves off and
you say alright what can I do this
always a solution you can't expect
people always get mistaken that just
because because this fear has been what
it has been it's been because I
consistently work transfer about 10
years so now I know my job enough to be
able to be appreciated for it but if I
hadn't had the last 10 years I would
never have had this year or the year
before that so success is not a
destination where you or power is not
like okay today you're powerful you're
to consistently be powerful and
consistently be successful and that is a
journey it will never be as them I'm
really confused where is the switch ON
switch off button three hundo and you
come to the very card to do a Kashi
buy-in so convincingly yeah that whole
last scene when he calls me must I mean
I came down for a weekend to shoot it I
showed it over Saturday Sunday it was it
was a hectic trick tip but I think
that's my job my process is very
different I'm not I don't conventionally
nobody taught me what acting was about
my acting school have been my career my
gurus have been my filmmakers and my co
actors so I think I learned my own
process which is I create a personality
I don't work I'm not someone who needs
to stay in the mood or I don't go sow
into a character I create the person I
like a create Kashia I think about what
she likes how she'd behave you know what
her choices are what her favorite food
is you can ask me anything about a
character and I know them they're like
they become like my best friends or my
sisters and after that I don't need to
stay in the mood because I know them so
well you can throw anything at me and
I'll be able to do it
so my process is very different because
of which I can switch on and off really
well I was different I still am
different and in a country which is very
far far away from home very far away
from familiarity and I think that's what
my strengths are
[Music]
when I was young I didn't understand
that when I was a kid in school when I
was bullied when I didn't understand who
I was turning into but what makes you
different if you identify that and you
realize that all right this is what's
different about me if you think about it
that's exactly what makes us special
that's exactly we'll make sure unique
and you need to just and I do that over
time be the best version of yourself
because the more different you are the
most special you are